Caption: hi i'm kerry muse and i'm here at ddd
Caption: perth to talk to you about things i
Caption: learnt from my mentors
Caption: so first up i want to call out and say
Caption: thank you to the amazing sponsors of ddd
Caption: per that have made the event today
Caption: possible
Caption: and next up i just want to go through
Caption: why i'm here to talk to you about
Caption: mentors
Caption: mentors are people that
Caption: have inspired me
Caption: and honestly without their influence i
Caption: wouldn't have gotten up here and decided
Caption: to try and give a talk today
Caption: they're people that help you work smart
Caption: and not hard set better goals for
Caption: yourself and actually help you achieve
Caption: those goals faster
Caption: so today why are you here and what can
Caption: you actually do with this information
Caption: about what my mentors told me well i
Caption: think i've got a lot of helpful advice
Caption: that you can use if you're just starting
Caption: on your career in tech or going through
Caption: a career transformation like i've just
Caption: done
Caption: or if you are already professional
Caption: working in technology it's information
Caption: that might be a bit of a reminder that
Caption: you can apply for yourself again
Caption: lastly what i really want you to take
Caption: from this talk is information that you
Caption: can share with other people people that
Caption: you come across that are starting on
Caption: their journey and think about the things
Caption: that are actually really helpful for a
Caption: beginner
Caption: so for me where did i start well my
Caption: journey starts in january of last year i
Caption: stepped into a role or was offered a
Caption: role which was a temporary position
Caption: without much security working closer in
Caption: it i'd come from working in the business
Caption: side getting user adoption providing
Caption: some training and i actually started to
Caption: work on that system that i've been
Caption: working with
Caption: so suddenly that made me being the least
Caption: experienced person and i had a lot to
Caption: learn
Caption: first i needed to learn how to ask for
Caption: help
Caption: and work out what i wanted to do study
Caption: wise
Caption: first step was playing with a little bit
Caption: of a tafe course where i looked at doing
Caption: some understanding databases
Caption: and then i was fortunate enough to be
Caption: accepted into the she codes plus program
Caption: which was a six month intensive course
Caption: on coding which included some things
Caption: that were helpful for me in that current
Caption: job and just some really useful
Caption: understanding and most importantly
Caption: access to some mentors
Caption: so where am i now so at this point 18
Caption: months later july 2021 i am feeling
Caption: confident having technical conversations
Caption: i get to solve technical problems which
Caption: i love doing
Caption: i have learnt some programming and how
Caption: to code and i feel ready that i can
Caption: start approaching new topics
Caption: the she codes plus 2020 alumni member
Caption: which feels amazing and i've just
Caption: recently gotten six microsoft
Caption: certifications to back up the other
Caption: study that i've done
Caption: and most importantly i've started an
Caption: amazing job and now feel so much more
Caption: secure in my career
Caption: for now we just want to go through and
Caption: think about what a mentor is because
Caption: once i started bringing this all
Caption: together i realized it means something
Caption: different to a lot of people
Caption: the key thing that i find is a mentor is
Caption: someone who can help you with your
Caption: professional or personal development
Caption: someone that you trust and someone that
Caption: you respect but most importantly they
Caption: need to be open to having a conversation
Caption: with you and talking to you
Caption: so for me what makes someone a mentor
Caption: for me it's not around a
Caption: formal arrangement where they talk to me
Caption: once a month and guide me through a
Caption: process it's something that i drive with
Caption: people informally and access them based
Caption: on their area of expertise
Caption: they don't need to be just a role model
Caption: where they have multiple things that i
Caption: want to admire they can have some areas
Caption: that aren't the best but most they're
Caption: really people humans and many of them
Caption: and main thing is with all of these
Caption: connections that i've made is me as the
Caption: mentor mentee is overall responsible for
Caption: what i do and i'm setting the goals
Caption: so
Caption: just getting you ready into these
Caption: amazing things that i'm saying they've
Caption: told me i just want to go through some
Caption: of the basics that i needed to be told
Caption: as a beginner that you may not realize
Caption: the things that need to be taught to
Caption: people
Caption: so
Caption: the first one is time boxing which is
Caption: something that needed to be sort of
Caption: explained to me even though the name can
Caption: give it away and this is just about
Caption: defining a period of time
Caption: to the problem that you're tackling this
Caption: can be used to tackle something you're
Caption: not looking forward to doing or it could
Caption: be to think about how long you want to
Caption: give a technical problem and the
Caption: solution that you're trying out before
Caption: stopping and asking for help
Caption: so here set your time limit once that's
Caption: up
Caption: walk away is normally step i need to
Caption: take grab a cup of coffee
Caption: and come back and assess your progress
Caption: when you're at this stage this is when
Caption: you start to consider if you need to ask
Caption: for help and maybe also just rethink
Caption: your approach
Caption: and the next thing that was key in
Caption: learning and understanding is realizing
Caption: that i will never know everything no one
Caption: will ever know everything
Caption: moving into the technology space is
Caption: about being comfortable in not knowing
Caption: and asking questions
Caption: it's about continued learning and
Caption: realizing you're constantly on that
Caption: growth stage
Caption: and first thing i started to realize is
Caption: even experts need to ask for help
Caption: sometimes
Caption: on starting to learn an important
Caption: concept i needed to realize was about
Caption: foundations first there's an abundance
Caption: of things that you can learn and it's
Caption: easy to try and chop and change test
Caption: things out so using an example of code
Caption: and programming i want to talk to you
Caption: about say learning python
Caption: so you pick the one thing
Caption: and you start
Caption: the main thing is realistically to
Caption: define what it is that you're trying to
Caption: do with what you're trying to learn so
Caption: with python it could be find out how to
Caption: analyze some certain data or build
Caption: something
Caption: from here it's really around getting
Caption: that item done and sticking with it so
Caption: if indentation errors are driving you
Caption: absolutely crazy and you've heard that
Caption: python and indentation are a bit of a
Caption: thing that you're not going to encounter
Caption: with the next language you could be
Caption: trying to jump ship what i'm saying is
Caption: you need to really stick that out and
Caption: finish that goal because these are
Caption: things that you're going to be able to
Caption: transfer
Caption: you don't need to become an expert but
Caption: these foundation principles that you've
Caption: learned from python will carry across
Caption: when you try and learn some more
Caption: programming
Caption: and the key thing is here when you look
Caption: back i know that you're probably going
Caption: to think those indentation errors were
Caption: actually useful it was an error message
Caption: that actually told me what the problem
Caption: was what was i thinking
Caption: from here i want to talk about writing
Caption: some things down so it's something
Caption: you're told probably no matter what
Caption: industry you're in but is really
Caption: important with technology documentation
Caption: is a big part of technical roles that
Caption: doesn't often get spoken about
Caption: before writing notes down for yourself i
Caption: encourage you to store these in
Caption: something you can access anywhere or
Caption: online
Caption: one note notion if you've not heard of
Caption: is another online tool and even keeping
Caption: things in github can be really useful
Caption: and shareable
Caption: when i need to learn something that
Caption: requires more than three steps i work on
Caption: a checklist i
Caption: quickly realized that a few months later
Caption: i don't remember that much and i need to
Caption: go through and remind myself of the
Caption: steps
Caption: and importantly the other thing is try
Caption: and write things down in a way that you
Caption: can send other people when they ask the
Caption: question
Caption: they'll appreciate it and if they do the
Caption: same i'm sure they're going to return
Caption: the favor when you ask them
Caption: from here i couldn't be talking about
Caption: what mentors told me without the things
Caption: that they constantly reinforce which is
Caption: to put a meaningful comments in your
Caption: code and make sure your commit messages
Caption: say something helpful
Caption: from here i want to cover a bit about
Caption: how to document things down
Caption: and if you're in a position where you're
Caption: helping somebody out i'd really
Caption: encourage you to see if you can just
Caption: show them a little bit about how you
Caption: store information about what they're
Caption: asking about
Caption: for me i
Caption: was getting a lot of different links and
Caption: a lot of different resources and
Caption: bookmarks are actually a really
Caption: impractical way to store that
Caption: information
Caption: i've started to use notion to store the
Caption: link and index it against what that sort
Caption: of particular topic's about and maybe do
Caption: some other tags that are meaningful and
Caption: i can actually go through and sort
Caption: through that when i can't remember the
Caption: name of the tool i was told about a few
Caption: months later
Caption: the other thing is again that advice i
Caption: was given is to consider making it so
Caption: you can actually publish these notes
Caption: online somewhere if you've had to google
Caption: something three or four different ways
Caption: in order to find this information
Caption: chances are someone else is doing the
Caption: same thing and you can share that
Caption: information and start to connect with
Caption: other people
Caption: lastly this is something that was
Caption: groundbreaking idea for me but might be
Caption: obvious to other people but i still i
Caption: still want to call it out
Caption: it's
Caption: when i was writing notes down if i
Caption: couldn't find a logical space i would
Caption: either spend hours reorganizing my notes
Caption: so i could put it somewhere or not write
Caption: that piece of information down
Caption: someone showed me putting things into a
Caption: tidbit section
Caption: if i need to find it later all these
Caption: online tools have a search feature
Caption: anyway but at least i've written it down
Caption: and moved on with my day and the task at
Caption: hand
Caption: so rubber ducking which experienced
Caption: developers probably know well too well
Caption: it's a book it's come from the book the
Caption: pragmatic programmer the idea of rubber
Caption: ducking is sitting when you're trying to
Caption: debug your code describing it line by
Caption: line to a duck
Caption: as if
Caption: figuring out where the problem is
Caption: i have used this as well just in general
Caption: talking out loud about technical
Caption: problems that i'm trying to solve
Caption: and working through what that's going to
Caption: be
Caption: now your rubber duck doesn't need to be
Caption: a piece of plastic it can be your pet it
Caption: can be a friend it can be your spouse i
Caption: also find that sometimes just pretending
Caption: to write out a message or an email in
Caption: the process of typing out the question
Caption: has helped me work out what i'm trying
Caption: to figure out and come closer to the
Caption: solution
Caption: the step that i always try and follow
Caption: after i get past this rubber duck thing
Caption: is whilst i get and start to understand
Caption: the problems i need to take in english
Caption: is to write it down in pseudocode being
Caption: a mismatch of whatever language i'm
Caption: trying to write it in and english
Caption: and when i start to step through and get
Caption: the syntax right i still can keep sight
Caption: of the next few steps i'm trying to
Caption: follow
Caption: from here i thought it'd be a good
Caption: chance to tell you aside from rubber
Caption: ducks there's some other cool things
Caption: that i learned from my mentors the first
Caption: one which i use embarrassingly often and
Caption: rave about is my favorite keyboard
Caption: shortcut i learned last year for windows
Caption: it's as spacebar and full stop and for
Caption: mac it's control command control and
Caption: space and that just brings up an emoji
Caption: keyboard you can put this in wherever
Caption: you want but it's useful to have on hand
Caption: from there i also thought i'd call out
Caption: to a
Caption: something that saved me a couple hours a
Caption: few times is bracket pair colorizer
Caption: which is a vs code extension to help you
Caption: match up where your closing brackets
Caption: might have gone a little bit wonky
Caption: and undraw which is just an image
Caption: library it comes with some standard
Caption: images what i've used in this
Caption: presentation that you can actually set
Caption: the color to
Caption: i find it really helpful to have things
Caption: like this bookmarked and on hand because
Caption: whilst i'm not working full time as a
Caption: web developer i've got some resources i
Caption: can refer to when i need something in a
Caption: pinch
Caption: flatikon.com is another useful place to
Caption: get images and colors.lol is one of many
Caption: color palette pickers that are out there
Caption: it just happens to be the url that i
Caption: remember when i need something
Caption: now i'm going to update and have the
Caption: information available of my favorite
Caption: items available on github which is
Caption: hellocareerlead.github.io
Caption: so you can access these links easily
Caption: afterwards
Caption: so
Caption: next up i want to take you through some
Caption: less common advice and really
Caption: some of the super meaningful things that
Caption: aren't necessarily things i hear or have
Caption: been told more than once
Caption: so
Caption: the first step is helping others while
Caption: you're still learning so you may not
Caption: feel like an expert but explaining
Caption: something that you've just learned
Caption: is what i found the best way to really
Caption: cement my understanding
Caption: i found that beginners often spot
Caption: beginner problems
Caption: going through the sheikahs program
Caption: working with other women learning how to
Caption: code at the same time
Caption: i had a situation where five mentors had
Caption: come up scratched their head and
Caption: couldn't work out what on earth was
Caption: going wrong with what i was doing and
Caption: why it wasn't working
Caption: i ended up going in the too hard section
Caption: of the room with a couple of other girls
Caption: where a few people had looked at
Caption: couldn't figure out what on earth it was
Caption: i
Caption: thought mine was lost cause tried to
Caption: help the girl that was sitting over
Caption: there with me
Caption: and we able to go through steps she was
Caption: ahead of where i was but i actually
Caption: helped figure out what her problem was
Caption: and gotta run away
Caption: now
Caption: she insisted that she try and do the
Caption: same for me even though so many people
Caption: had just
Caption: couldn't work out what was going on
Caption: and she actually spotted what the issue
Caption: was immediately because as a beginner
Caption: it's a mistake she'd made and something
Caption: she'd written down but it was something
Caption: assumed by any developer that was
Caption: looking at it
Caption: the other thing is really talking to
Caption: other people learning makes you realize
Caption: there's so many different ways that you
Caption: can tackle a problem
Caption: and helps you think about other ways of
Caption: thinking about technical issues
Caption: and lastly if all else fails you can
Caption: always be their rubber duck and help
Caption: them talk through the issue
Caption: now on learning and something i've taken
Caption: away from going through a course
Caption: learning about coding was really when i
Caption: start to find out about new technical
Caption: item coding language or some other tool
Caption: that i'm using i approach it by building
Caption: a project first
Caption: so not only does this help you get a
Caption: portfolio of work but it is just really
Caption: a great way to learn so i start by doing
Caption: one tutorial and limiting myself to that
Caption: i then go around and ask people around
Caption: that i might know to work out what a
Caption: good project would be for that
Caption: technology so at the moment i'm wanting
Caption: to learn more about.net framework
Caption: so i've reached out to people i know
Caption: that work in that space and asked what
Caption: would be a good idea for a project
Caption: by talking to a mentor she said maybe
Caption: not using blazer and suggested i create
Caption: an app to store my friends date of
Caption: births so at the moment i'm now working
Caption: through
Caption: getting requirements together for me to
Caption: work through
Caption: because i actually need a bit of a
Caption: framework i get a little bit distracted
Caption: and a little bit too creative otherwise
Caption: and i'm going to set myself a time frame
Caption: on when i want to finish this buy again
Caption: for myself
Caption: um
Caption: and the idea isn't to be horrible i'm
Caption: still flexible with myself i've just got
Caption: a set goal and i'm keeping it fun
Caption: from here i want to talk a little bit
Caption: more about certification certifications
Caption: are what helped me bridge what i learnt
Caption: at work and what i learned through
Caption: g-codes and all of my self-study
Caption: together to really help shape my career
Caption: so for me
Caption: validating all of that information was
Caption: key
Caption: and i'll talk a bit more around
Caption: microsoft certifications because that's
Caption: what i know and i've had recent
Caption: experience with but i understand this
Caption: pretty much applies straight across to
Caption: your aws search and other technology
Caption: that you're going to learn
Caption: so
Caption: first thing is there's online training
Caption: days particularly since 2020 more and
Caption: more online training days have become
Caption: available from these certification
Caption: providers and they are
Caption: free a lot of the time so can you really
Caption: give some tips on preparing for that
Caption: particular exam during those days
Caption: and also make sure you look at the
Caption: learning materials available for by
Caption: who's setting the exam
Caption: there's lots of pathways available
Caption: microsoft learn and lots of information
Caption: in the documentation
Caption: from here when you start thinking about
Caption: preparing for your exam
Caption: even if the end certificate that you're
Caption: wanting to get is a little bit higher
Caption: level
Caption: still start with a basic exam often they
Caption: might be a little bit cheaper you easier
Caption: to access but the key thing is preparing
Caption: for these exams it's a bit of a strange
Caption: environment if you haven't done a
Caption: multiple choice test for a long time you
Caption: kind of forget the strange nuances
Caption: involved there so take the time to start
Caption: with the basic exam and make sure you're
Caption: ready to go when you start to challenge
Caption: yourself a little bit more
Caption: from here i just want to talk you
Caption: through a little bit about how i prepare
Caption: the exams and some of the advice that i
Caption: received
Caption: so for me i needed to get the date
Caption: booked and set a time frame for when i
Caption: wanted to attend the exam
Caption: if you're doing this i encourage you to
Caption: also have a look at what your
Caption: cancellation window is or your rebooking
Caption: window is and maybe set yourself a
Caption: reminder just before that expires too
Caption: what i then do is find where the
Caption: resource is available for exam contents
Caption: and work out where the exam's weighted
Caption: and for me i dump that into something
Caption: that i can edit
Caption: and i straight away anything i think i
Caption: know inside out i delete i don't need to
Caption: think about that
Caption: and i flag yellow anything i've got no
Caption: idea what they're talking about
Caption: and leave the rest there and review the
Caption: waiting
Caption: and then that's where i focus on my
Caption: learning on
Caption: from here i generally honestly sometimes
Caption: forget about my exam for a little while
Caption: and repeat that exercise couple hours
Caption: before the exam making sure i research
Caption: any of those problem areas immediately
Caption: before the exam hits and hoping i retain
Caption: that information
Caption: the next thing is online proctoring
Caption: which is a
Caption: really useful thing that's available but
Caption: something just to be aware of the exam
Caption: conditions are a little bit strange
Caption: having someone watching you through a
Caption: webcam
Caption: and there's a bit of advice they warn
Caption: you about but a few things that can
Caption: easily catch you out is they generally
Caption: only allow one screen
Caption: and that means you can't plug your
Caption: laptop into a monitor and have your
Caption: laptop on your desk
Caption: they often have a rule only allowing you
Caption: to have water
Caption: even if it doesn't say that specifically
Caption: you can get called out for having a
Caption: coffee on your desk
Caption: and look
Caption: it's just
Caption: it's a bit intense having someone
Caption: watching you like that and to be aware
Caption: for aware of it i've gotten called out
Caption: because my cat's walked across the room
Caption: and my eyes have come off the screen for
Caption: a few seconds
Caption: it's what it is it's convenient doing it
Caption: at home but just be aware it's a pretty
Caption: unusual setting and you start to get
Caption: used to it with a few more exams
Caption: lastly once you've nailed that exam and
Caption: passed it make sure that you stop and
Caption: celebrate on linkedin and share that
Caption: information you can link up those
Caption: certifications
Caption: straight through to your linkedin
Caption: profile so the verified
Caption: cert shows up straight away and get that
Caption: recognition
Caption: so
Caption: on career advice at this point i've
Caption: talked about
Caption: what i've been learning at work what
Caption: i've certified and finishing off she
Caption: codes i need to start planning what my
Caption: next steps were going to be
Caption: so
Caption: for me i had the pleasure of having an
Caption: amazing boss and a great working
Caption: environment but just a little bit growth
Caption: restricted in that role so i had time on
Caption: my side to start thinking about things i
Caption: started talking to people who maybe have
Caption: hired but weren't hiring at that time to
Caption: get a bit of information informally
Caption: around interview processes different
Caption: roles that i might be suitable for and
Caption: information that maybe i'd done and
Caption: teasing out what was super impressive
Caption: that i'd done and knowing what to
Caption: actually put onto my cv
Caption: from here i also kept an eye on
Caption: different roles and constantly having a
Caption: look at what skills would be
Caption: transferable that i needed to include in
Caption: my job applications and make sure i'd
Caption: highlighted from previous work
Caption: experience
Caption: i
Caption: strongly suggest that when you start
Caption: working in it and need to interview to
Caption: ask a few questions about the interview
Caption: format and just being prepared if you're
Caption: going to be going in for a technical
Caption: interview and
Caption: understand what sort of questions might
Caption: pop up
Caption: the key thing which is something that
Caption: doesn't necessarily definitely applies
Caption: to it but you may not necessarily have
Caption: experienced before is that you need to
Caption: understand the salaries before you get
Caption: to those conversations
Caption: you normally need to actually give what
Caption: sort of salary expectations you're after
Caption: rather than being prompted and asked and
Caption: that's something that i was definitely
Caption: not comfortable with and really needed
Caption: to have research before i found myself
Caption: in that position and i'm very lucky that
Caption: someone warned me about that
Caption: so next up i really want to go through
Caption: understanding what you want
Caption: because i had
Caption: gone through a transition and i had a
Caption: variety of different experience and
Caption: technical skills under my belt
Caption: i
Caption: kind of didn't want exactly coding all
Caption: day at a junior level i didn't want just
Caption: talking about this application i wanted
Caption: to find a way to combine the different
Caption: things that i liked
Caption: and to be honest i wasn't very good at
Caption: communicating how that was going to work
Caption: out
Caption: i was fortunate enough to be set up on a
Caption: coffee date with someone who
Caption: worked in a technical role but not
Caption: really related at all to what i did in
Caption: i.t to help tease out of me how and what
Caption: on earth i was talking about so i could
Caption: have those conversations
Caption: and i was taken through this exercise
Caption: that i did for myself and i want to talk
Caption: to you about because it's made such a
Caption: big difference for me
Caption: so there's a few things to think about
Caption: with any role
Caption: first off if title or what the actual
Caption: role is called is important to you
Caption: uh if you
Caption: care about having an idea of what sort
Caption: of salary you're expecting
Caption: and
Caption: from there think about the boss that you
Caption: want to work with and this is where
Caption: this advice sort of changes a little bit
Caption: so this is do you want to mentor at this
Caption: stage in your career do you want a boss
Caption: that just leaves you alone and lets you
Caption: decide what you do this is this is a
Caption: personal thing um
Caption: next off is what do you want your team
Caption: to be like for me i wanted to be around
Caption: other technical people who were
Caption: constantly challenging themselves and
Caption: sharing new technical discoveries and
Caption: that was what was key for me
Caption: the other thing is location this is more
Caption: and more port important in a
Caption: covered world then we've gotten used to
Caption: working from home if you need to have
Caption: some work from home or a distance from
Caption: the office
Caption: right
Caption: have a think about that and lastly is
Caption: what are your day-to-day duties what
Caption: does your ideal day look like to you
Caption: so for me
Caption: it was a matter of writing these things
Caption: down even though not all of these things
Caption: were exactly important to me
Caption: i knew what was
Caption: and having it there
Caption: once i knew my day-to-day boss colleague
Caption: situation i was far more prepared to
Caption: have conversations about with possible
Caption: employers or recruiters about what i
Caption: really wanted
Caption: the next step in going through this
Caption: process is keeping this just for you but
Caption: then also writing the same thing down
Caption: about where you want to be in two five
Caption: years what it might be for you for me it
Caption: was two years and i wrote this down
Caption: again and kept that i've kept that on
Caption: hand
Caption: so
Caption: all this advice sounds amazing tailored
Caption: just to me so i want to tell you about
Caption: finding mentors
Caption: so the first step is obviously to get
Caption: out and meet some people now
Caption: i was talking about going to events but
Caption: realistically it's just about getting
Caption: involved in something in the community
Caption: that can be online and there's plenty of
Caption: local based online things during these
Caption: times
Caption: but it's actually just getting out and
Caption: getting involved
Caption: for any women in technology or entering
Caption: technology in australia i need to shout
Caption: out she codes australia because they
Caption: were integral in the beginning of my
Caption: journey
Caption: and also technical meet-ups which are
Caption: a little bit scary and daunting if
Caption: you're just learning that technology but
Caption: are an amazing place to find people that
Caption: are excited about their technology and
Caption: want to talk about it
Caption: from here work this can be pretty
Caption: obvious but i'm going to call it out
Caption: friends and friends of friends your
Caption: friends probably have really good judge
Caption: of people you might want to hang around
Caption: with and they may know people that are
Caption: connected in that space that you want to
Caption: do
Caption: get a feel
Caption: you'd be surprised
Caption: and the last thing is technical people
Caption: are everywhere
Caption: so
Caption: what i actually really want to shout out
Caption: to is
Caption: i
Caption: had
Caption: an almost life-changing conversation
Caption: over the christmas new year period
Caption: borrowing a hammer from my neighbor
Caption: my neighbor was lovely chatty person and
Caption: when returning the hammer she decided to
Caption: ask what an earth it was i was building
Caption: and check out my lovely ikea dining room
Caption: table
Caption: once we got talking she started asking a
Caption: little bit about me and found out that i
Caption: was working in i.t and starting to think
Caption: about what i wanted to do next i then
Caption: find out that sally now retired had
Caption: spent her career in it and was quite
Caption: involved in different community things
Caption: we sat down and she
Caption: first off introduced me to the person
Caption: who took me out for the coffee and
Caption: taught me a bit about planning for my
Caption: career
Caption: she also talked to me and really built
Caption: my confidence around now my she codes
Caption: course had finished where mentors were
Caption: readily available for me how on earth i
Caption: was going to keep finding people that
Caption: would help me along my journey
Caption: sally herself was leaving perth so i got
Caption: made the most of the connections in the
Caption: conversations
Caption: so
Caption: from here
Caption: making these connections this is around
Caption: whenever you meet someone trying to be
Caption: open
Caption: friendly
Caption: and having a bit of an elevator pitch so
Caption: knowing what it is that you do and where
Caption: you want to go
Caption: and what interests you that's going to
Caption: help you prepare for
Caption: a leading and amazing conversation
Caption: this is really goes for if you're going
Caption: to an event and hoping to find someone
Caption: who's going to give you some guidance
Caption: don't just think about what you want
Caption: from them think about how you're going
Caption: to present yourself to them so they want
Caption: to engage with you
Caption: from here it's really around
Caption: connecting using socials i want to call
Caption: out it sounds obvious linkedin and
Caption: twitter as an appropriate place to
Caption: follow up those conversations and those
Caption: people you meet with
Caption: when it comes to actually engaging your
Caption: mentors
Caption: it's for me it's around having lots
Caption: of people that i can ask questions i
Caption: don't use the formal mental word with a
Caption: lot of these people
Caption: and honestly some of the advice i've
Caption: already called out has come off from
Caption: single conversations
Caption: but
Caption: really they did mentor me
Caption: so when i
Caption: approach someone i need to know what i'm
Caption: asking i know what i'm asking for and
Caption: what i'm really expecting from them so i
Caption: can make it clear that it's something
Caption: they can be comfortable with i'm not
Caption: going to ask them something that's going
Caption: to put them in an uncomfortable position
Caption: about things that go on with their
Caption: employer it's something that is easy for
Caption: them to be able to help with
Caption: i express my thanks and show gratitude
Caption: and most importantly i think it's
Caption: mentors love to know that you're someone
Caption: who's actually going to go out there and
Caption: return the favor and help other people
Caption: as well
Caption: so the next step with this is actually
Caption: acknowledging and celebrating success
Caption: so if someone's taking you on a journey
Caption: and helped you find out maybe they've
Caption: bought you a book on a programming
Caption: language or given you some useful links
Caption: if you write and have hello world show
Caption: up on your screen they're still going to
Caption: smile when they hear about that let them
Caption: know
Caption: if i've automated something instead of
Caption: doing it manually based on the advice
Caption: that someone told me a few months ago
Caption: i've let them know and they've loved
Caption: hearing about it because that's what we
Caption: like to do in technology right
Caption: the next thing is celebrating when you
Caption: advance your job and expressing it and
Caption: saying thank you and celebrating with
Caption: these people
Caption: and sometimes it's just about being more
Caption: confident having technical conversations
Caption: there's people in my life that i can
Caption: have completely different conversations
Caption: with then i could even 6-12 months ago
Caption: and
Caption: love it the last thing is celebrating
Caption: success for me it's giving a talk at a
Caption: developer conference is not something i
Caption: thought i'd be doing at this point i'm
Caption: so happy and i'm definitely celebrating
Caption: that with my mentors
Caption: what i wanted you to take away from this
Caption: is really
Caption: most people out there are willing to
Caption: help and just engage with them be
Caption: friendly
Caption: and make it easy for them to be able to
Caption: do it
Caption: if they
Caption: if you're engaging with someone in it
Caption: generally speaking they can't say no to
Caption: a cup of coffee invite them out and see
Caption: what you can find out just over that
Caption: informal chat
Caption: and in general things are just easier if
Caption: you ask for help
Caption: i do want to call out and say thank you
Caption: to everyone that's really helped me on
Caption: my journey to date
Caption: look obviously everyone involved in she
Caption: codes australia and the amazing support
Caption: i've received from ddd perth in
Caption: preparing the conference
Caption: i want to thank all out everyone i've
Caption: worked with in the past two years and
Caption: going forward the team that i've just
Caption: joined for calling out and saying thank
Caption: you
Caption: the people that i've chatted with
Caption: informally
Caption: in my apartment building at parties
Caption: everything that i've come across and
Caption: have given me a little bit of advice
Caption: along my way
Caption: and again it is just a big thank you for
Caption: the friends and family that have helped
Caption: me support me over this journey and
Caption: i wish i could just credit you all for
Caption: the amazing advice but there's been so
Caption: much that i can't keep track of at all
Caption: thank you